we begin this hour with the issue
affecting millions of households student
debt the federal government suspended
student loan payments during the
pandemic but americans will likely need
to start paying again next year and the
numbers are staggering check this out
more than 45 million people in the u.s
owe nearly two trillion dollars yep
trillion dollars we found out how some
schools are trying to ease the financial
burden for students while some lawmakers
want to reset the system entirely
is all student debt cleared at the
university from 2020 in february
then in the fall of 20 and then in
spring of 21
we eliminated student debt
on the campus of cheyney university just
outside philadelphia they're trying a
new solution to an ever growing problem
they already were facing a lot of issues
with covet yeah okay we had money
through the american rescue plan and we
said you know what this is something we
have to share
aaron walton is the president of cheyney
the country's oldest hbcu they're one of
a handful of schools actively reducing
the burden of tuition debt on current
students and that debt has skyrocketed
over the past decade student debt has
seen a 100 percent increase with
borrowers averaging nearly 40 thousand
dollars in old payment and for black
graduates that number is even higher
they owe on average about twenty four
thousand dollars more than white
graduates have you had conversations
about
what student
debt forgiveness has meant to students
here their families had suffered as a
result of pandemic they were thinking
about dropping out of school because
they needed help at home and the fact
that we were able to pay off their debt
for that term allowed them to stay here
so we impact more than just a student
we impact family before the pandemic i
ate breakfast lunch and dinner with the
students every day in the cafeteria
i live on campus
i'm here 24 hours a day seven days a
week do i know them
probably too well i was able to furnish
my apartment a little bit get myself a
bed
like i didn't have to sleep on the floor
you were sleeping on the floor yeah for
a while junior shimar palacio is one of
those students eating meals at the
university's cafeteria alongside walton
the 20 year old who one day wants to
work in graphic design had his balance
zeroed out earlier this semester
he thought it was a joke what did the
email say it was just like hey
if you owed us anything from the years
of
spring 2021 back to fall of 2020
spring of 2020
you're you're done you're clear i had a
huge back balance and going into the
semester was going to be tough really
tough for me so i was how am i going to
get this done canceling student loan
debt is the single most effective
executive action that president biden
can take to help close the racial wealth
gap the ballooning student debt crisis
has grabbed the attention of lawmakers
in washington president biden has an
opportunity and a responsibility
including representative ayanna presley
of massachusetts if i was president
biden and you were sitting across from
him right now
and you could speak your heart on this
issue what would you say to him i would
say we find ourselves in an
unprecedented moment
which presents an unprecedented
opportunity
and responsibility cancel student debt
this is transformative it is directly
impactful
it is an economic justice issue it is a
racial justice issue so you have the
authority stroke of a pen
just do it
writing administration has already
canceled 11.5 billion dollars in student
debt for more than half a million
american borrowers hopefully it shows up
in our policy but presley wants to see
more from the president and his
education department so when president
biden says
this is on congress to pass legislation
to forgive numbers this large is that
simply just an excuse i'm a firm
believer in the power of legislation
every option should be on the table
however
why go through a legislative process
when president biden has the authority
to immediately
right now stop the herd you don't know
the
relief that gives to your students your
shirt says love a little more is that
what the university did for you and the
students here i see cheney as a family
so love a little more definitely when it
comes to cheney for me like i love
everyone here they've given me so much
it represents choice
back at cheney president walton sees the
jester buyers university not as a
handout but as an investment
in people so we've got to look at
retention
how do we keep these students we lose
some opportunities
to have folks at cheyney that will be
the next ed bradleys who happened to
work for cbs the great they graduated
from janie so it's about access and
and opportunity for our students so
it's a small investment that we made
for permanent
improvement if it's not us through six
degrees of separation we all know
somebody's dealing with dealing with
student loan debt yeah you know now
there's another side to this coin if you
will
that this could be geared towards the
rich um this student loan forgiveness
but then also people who recently paid
off their loans how do they feel about
it and i asked ayanna presley
and she said well don't we want the next
generation to have it easier than us
that's what you think i mean we also
live in a country where most people
don't have a college degree right so but
i think part of the reason that that's
the case is because they see that burden
of debt and they don't want to take it
on and when you burden young people it
presses them down for their life they
don't start families on track they don't
buy homes on track it changes the
trajectory of their life it's a ripple
effect yeah and we all need these people
to be on the way up not pressed down
well well you see the difference it
makes but i like president walton saying
it's not a handout it's an investment
yes that's i think that's a really
important way to look at it